our final story this morning is a very
powerful and personal one for our good
friend Michelle she's been reporting for
nearly 20 years at CBS News Michelle has
covered Landmark social justice stories
and life-changing natural disasters like
Hurricane Katrina now she's telling her
own story sharing a painful Family
secret that lasted for her entire life
her new Memoir belonging A daughter's
search for identity through loss and
love focuses on the mother who abandoned
her she writes as a motherless child I
had learned that identity is shaped as
much by those who are absent in our
lives as those who stand by our side
Michelle
let's talk a little bit about this book
now your father is African-American your
mother is Latino yes and she presented
as white as you said it she she looked
white the way she was described to me
early on was that she was white so it
was a it was sort of this vagueness
people didn't talk about my dad my
grandmother didn't really talk about her
very much outside of the fact that she
was quote unquote Caucasian so when did
you learn how much race played a role in
her abandonment not until Elementary for
school which is where we all find those
discoveries about who we are and our
place in this world and it was um sort
of Stark I'm from South Central Los
Angeles and everyone around me were
nuclear families so being the child who
went to school with her grandmother and
her father present and no Mom that's
when the question started what you do
that is so powerful in this book and I
think will be so relatable to so many
people is you explain how you can have a
roof over your head loving people in
your life food on the table but still
because of this absence have the sense
of loss that creeps into the corners of
your life could you talk about that yes
no so for me I was never angry
um as a child it seemed it seemed to
make sense to me my dad would describe
my origin story like this your mother
and father fell in love we had you then
your mother couldn't be there anymore
she left your father mother and you and
it just okay my dad never really talked
about it my grandmother didn't talk
about it it wasn't until I had my own
children that it started to creep in in
a way this need for acknowledgment
because it was my children now who were
who were being deprived of the knowledge
of their ancestry and so the Tale in the
book really takes you through this
evolution of how I feel and felt about
my mother in her absence as a child
through my adolescence and then as an
adult and having my own children one of
the many tragedies in the book is the
tragedy that you discover which is your
mother your birth mother and your father
were actually deeply in love she had a
love for him that you believe to be
genuine yes and I believe my father
loved her it's my father is a character
in this book love him deeply have so
much pride for him because he was a
wonderful father but they had this
long-standing relationship for seven
years how do you have a seven year
relationship with someone who one was
married yeah that's another application
that's a huge complication but but when
her parents and her family found out
that she was even dating a black man
these are this is a latinx family in Los
Angeles California working class they
too were marginalized and yet the
thought was it's him or us it's him or
us and so she lived with this secret it
wasn't a secret that I lived with anyone
who ever asked me about it I was always
very clear about
um in what I knew but but the secret
hanging over me is probably why I live
out loud the way I do it as you well
know out loud liver but just just um it
I'm sure it had an impact on on the way
I am yeah and you mentioned um
self-worth which I think it's something
we all struggle with throughout our
lives and how has getting all of this
out in this format allowed you to see
yourself in a different way
oh I'm still grappling with that yeah um
I'm still in the process of that you
know people when they say they write a
book they it seems as though it's been
their therapy it is like oh I've solved
all the problems I am still very
um
I'm grappling with it all yeah uh
acknowledgment is really important to me
it's important not important all of us
personally it is and that is why I think
I cover the stories I do to acknowledge
people who are often times left
unacknowledged it's it's a Common Thread
through your worth it's a Common Thread
it really is and I really have to thank
uh CBS mornings at the time CBS This
Morning for this book uh Brian Bingham
our senior producer I'm sure he has lost
your title then but he was our senior
producer and he assigned a story to me
that aired five days or six days after
George Floyd's murder in which she asked
me to uh through all of the coverage
I've done over the last 30 years and
covering policing and communities and
the struggles in between to give a
perspective on why this seemed like a
different moment the 2020 protest the
social justice movement and I took a
22nd can turn and I turn the lens on why
racism has impacted me and it's obvious
um I was my mother's secret it cost you
your mother and and your family your
father is a renowned surgeon he was the
first person on the scene when Bobby
Kennedy was shot in California uh and
yet despite the wonders of your family
this other person's family said no we
can't be part of that and the law said
they suffered for not knowing you I
don't want to give away the end of the
book but what's so powerful about it is
you go on this journey you find the
people who weren't there and you get to
ask the questions and I think that's so
it's a dream for a lot of people yes and
I acknowledge those who are there those
who stayed those who came into my life
to raise me and I have created a
beautiful family there's a love story
here and friends and I can't thank you
all enough for being great colleagues oh
thank you I love the part how are you
mad
it goes on sale tomorrow we'll be right
back seriously congratulations thank you